[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID BARRY: Good morning.
Today at Google, we're delighted
to welcome Ellen Ullman.
Ellen wrote her first
computer program in 1978
and went on to be a programmer
and software engineer
for more than 20 years.
She is also the author of four
books, "Close to the Machine,"
a memoir published in
1997 about her experiences
as a programmer when
the internet was
approaching its first boom.
That went on to become a
cult classic description
of the programming life.
Her next book, "The Bug,"
a novel published in 2003
was about a programmer
who has a bug he
can't fix for a year and
the resultant unraveling
of his life.
Her third book,
another novel, titled
"By Blood" in 2013 was not
about technology at all, was it?
ELLEN ULLMAN: It shocked people.
Why isn't this about technology?
How could you write
about something that
happened before the internet?
My reply was, well,
modern human beings
have existed for 200,000 years;
modern internet about 20 years.
So things happened
before the internet.
DAVID BARRY: And then her
latest book, just released,
is "Life in Code: A Personal
History of Technology," which
contains new previously
unpublished essays spanning
from 1994 to 2017, traces
the continuing story
of how computer technology
has evolved year by year
over the past few decades.
And in it, Ellen describes
the coding culture
as it is lived inside the
society of programmers.
Ellen is a voice
that continually
looks at the ways in which
code and digital devices
affect our political, social,
civic, and deeply personal
lives, for good or ill.
Please join me in welcoming
to Google Ellen Ullman.
ELLEN ULLMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID BARRY: Thank you.
ELLEN ULLMAN: It's my pleasure.
DAVID BARRY: OK.
So you taught yourselves
to program in 1978
and then you went to become
a programmer and software
engineer for the
next 20 plus years.
But you've mentioned
that you never
intended on becoming a
programmer professionally.
So could you talk
about your motivation?
So you went from being an
English major in college
to a videographer
to a programmer.
And how was your motivation
different than someone
going into programming today?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Well, the
video portion of my life
taught me that I loved
working with machines.
I had never expected it.
It was also a political
and social motive.
We had local
showings and we felt
we had broken the bonds
that large corporations
and broadcasters and
advertisers had tied us up in.
And if it feels to use
something like the coming
of the personal computer,
it had that same feel.
We could change the world with
these small personal machines
that would enable us to do
what people could do apart
from our corporate blessings.
I found I loved the
work and I went on,
moved to San Francisco.
And one day I was walking
down Market Street
and in the window was a
TRS-80, affectionately known
as the trash 80.
And it was one of the earliest
microcomputers and on a whim,
I bought it.
I thought, what can you
do with this machine?
Can you make art?
It's just another one of
these small personal machines
that broke away
from the mainframe
and I thought,
well, I'll try this.
So I took it home.
Of course, it involved
programming, which I thought,
well, how hard can that be?
It did prove hard not
having done any programming,
but it was basic and didn't
take long to learn it,
except for the fact that
it produced spaghetti code.
If anyone ever
remembers it, you could
go go sub and go
to without a return
that you can put in explicitly
or that the language would
do for you.
So you were always stepping
on your own memory.
And it was quite a chore
to keep track of where
you went, how you come back.
But actually, that was great
training-- great training
over the years.
The first people I worked
with were all explorers.
If you know who
Stewart Brand is,
who now does the
Long Now Foundation
and who wrote the "Whole
Earth Electric Catalog,"
and around that formed the
first online community known
as the WELL.
We were just a bunch of
people who just thought this
might be fun, let's look at it.
It was a bunch of weirdos.
And if you read John Markoff's
book, "What the Dormouse Saw,"
the early days were
a bunch of people
who were stoners, and
trippers, and poets manque,
and just people who
thought this would
be a great break in culture.
So the motivation was
exploration and fun, actually.
We had a certain
passionate about this.
And I wonder how
that has changed.
I'd have to ask
the people who work
at Google what their motive
is-- do they come to this
with a sense of delight?
And I know the feeling
has changed the world,
but I get the sense it's a
highly competitive environment
and the lure of prestige
and of course money
may be a big part of it.
Now, I'd have to ask the
people who work here what
their motivation would be.
DAVID BARRY: So you've
talked about the advantages
of being self-taught in coding,
the attraction, the passion
to learn.
But what about
the disadvantages?
Is there a downside?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Oh, big downside.
I was aware that I had
these islands of knowledge
and these enormous chasms
between them and any day,
I was going to fall into
one of those chasms.
It produced an
underlying anxiety,
so confidence and anxiety
were at war with each other
all the time.
But I came to know that many
really skilled engineers
and computer scientists
felt the same way
if they were honest about it
or if they were self-aware.
I met a post-doc at
Berkeley and they
were reading "The Bug" at that
time and had a reading group.
And a woman there
ironically said,
oh, this guy who
couldn't fix the bug,
he should just get some therapy.
And a man who was a
post-doc said, oh, no.
This is my life.
This is exactly what
I feel every day.
So I know, OK, if you're
really aware that you
know some things very well
and some things decently well
and some things not at all,
it is a normal experience
for a software engineer.
DAVID BARRY: And
so in the book you
discuss the deep
social changes that
began with the first
wave of the internet
about this process of
disintermediation, which
was well underway by
1998, and how it fostered
a mistrust of experts
and intermediaries
who had until then mediated
society's interaction
with economic and social life.
Could you please discuss that?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Well, I'll work
backwards from the present.
It's no secret that we have
a president who disdains
journalism, experts
of all sorts--
even within our own government--
and of course tweets
over the heads of anybody
who is an intermediary
directly to what he imagines
are the people.
Now, this trend began--
well, it was very clear
by 1998 that the motive
was to break people away
from the intermediaries who
had worked for them--
brokers and agents and even
journalists,
especially librarians,
curators of all sorts and
go directly to a website.
Here we serve you.
You don't need all
those intermediaries.
They're not trustworthy,
they're out for themselves,
they're just to make money.
Just come to the web.
And that was a very
effective process.
And if you draw a line from 1998
to today and you unspool that,
you can see how we arrived at
the moment we're at today--
the disdain of
journalism, the mistrust
of professional news gatherers
and those who do analysis.
And the web had a
big part in this.
And we have to acknowledge that
it's not only the people who
are ignoring the intermediaries,
but the web itself
provided the enabling
technology to let this happen.
DAVID BARRY: Yeah.
And so for example, with
the most recent election,
there wasn't any intermediary,
there was no gatekeeper,
you didn't need the
approval of the party
elite or the newspapers
to run a campaign.
ELLEN ULLMAN: Anybody-- anyone
with experience and expertise
was put in doubt.
Only loyal people
were trusted and those
who could have
reasonable conversations
with our current
president were excluded.
And anytime someone
wanted to come in and have
a reasonable
conversation who had
years and decades
of experience was
ousted because that person
didn't agree wholeheartedly
with the president's
ideas, as they were.
And I think of Twitter as a
tremendous enabling technology.
And what Trump is
doing is exactly what
Twitter was designed to
do, which is broadcast what
I think of as a thought fart.
It's just it comes out
of you unconsidered,
nothing you can do about it--
boom, you post it.
And I'm not interested in
other people's thoughts
that just are of the moment.
Let's say you live with somebody
who does that all the time.
It is just maddening if you
have a spouse or a partner
and they walk by,
oh, well I thought
that dish should go
over there and I've
been thinking we should
move the paintings
or move the sofa at random.
You would go insane.
And I feel that the culture
is being manipulated and torn
in ways that are so unfortunate.
And the questioning of a common
truth began at least in 1998.
And the ingrained sense of
that is frightening to me
at this point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID BARRY: Yeah.
Go ahead.
ELLEN ULLMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I know
you said that--
DAVID BARRY: Do you think
that with the shortening
of attention spans people
don't have the patience
to refer to real
experts on the internet
and that they stick
with kind of a more
basic overview of non-experts?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Well,
I'm here at Google
and I don't want
to fault Google.
But of course, Google
is one of the behemoths
of the technical world
so it's not possible
for it to be totally
good and wonderful.
Years and years ago, I
knew Larry Page socially
through his brother, Carl.
We were friends.
And we went out to dinner
and I said to him, well,
the way your
algorithms work, you're
looking for the ones
with the most links
and it seems like the rich get
richer and the poor get poorer.
And Larry shrugged
and he said, well,
I don't know what
else I could do.
I'm sure it's all been
tweaked and changed
over these many years.
And I understood
him to say, there's
nothing else I can
do algorithmically.
And so the algorithm
may have changed,
but it doesn't go
and look exactly
for matches of what people are
looking for because the search
terms are so small.
And it doesn't really
have a serious way for you
to go through an
elaborate search input.
So how many people just use
Wikipedia as an authority?
I mean, you can answer
that question yourself.
I think you and
I'd like to think
that people who were doing
serious research would go down
and down and down to find
people who were educated
and who had discussed this and
who talked to other people who
had discussed this.
But we're creating a
generation now, two or three,
that has no motive to do that.
I don't know.
Term papers already are
Wikipedia recapitulations.
I mean, I used the "World
Book" way back then.
The teachers knew what it was
and they just scoffed at you.
I don't know what will
happen in the future.
It will take a team of
very dedicated people
like people at the
"Washington Post"
and the "New York Times" who
despite all value the work
they're doing and
persist in looking
for something balanced in the
world and something that's
authoritative.
Let's face it, people have
more authority than others.
I mean, all people are equal
but all opinions are not equal.
Some are much more
informed than others.
I don't know how to undo the
changes that have happened.
And I think it's up
to this generation
now, you, and those who follow
you to take a hard look at this
and see what they can do with
technology to wind this back.
DAVID BARRY: OK.
So changing gears a little bit,
about 1/4 of "Life in Code"
discusses artificial
intelligence.
And I realize this
is a big question,
but how do you think the
goals of AI have changed?
How are they different now
than, say, they were in 2000?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Huge question.
I will summarize it.
The original motive was to
discover what intelligence was,
that is human intelligence.
It was first thought to
be like a calculator.
The first computers
were calculators
and therefore, intelligence
was in calculation.
Chess was considered to be the
highest form of intelligence.
And then the steps were
to try to essentially
create a humanoid robot or
to incorporate into robotics
what human beings had.
Marvin Minsky
famously when asked--
do you know who
Marvin Minsky is?
Yes, good.
When asked, can
computers think, he
famously answered, of
course they can think.
I can think and
I'm a meat machine.
So then he thought it would
be solved in about five
or 10 years and then as
time passed, he said,
AI is the hardest problem
that science has undertaken.
A bit of hyperbole,
but the sense
of frustration in
trying to imbue
a machine with human
knowledge, a sentient computer
if you will, it's called
a spiritual robot.
That was a very strange
choice of words.
I get the sense now
that the human equation
is becoming less
important, that it's
machine to machine interface.
Self-driving cars are a
perfect example of that.
What's being done
is the idea that you
would sense another car and
eventually, that car would talk
to your car over the internet.
OK, that would be a
very insecure channel.
And so the experience of human
beings of 100 years of driving
is taken out of this.
And so I would
ask, let's go back
and see what humans
have to offer.
OK.
So when you, drive if
you're a good driver,
I'm saying we'll look at human
beings who are not distracted
who are good drivers.
You don't just consider
the proximity of the cars
around you.
You read the road.
You can see a car
moving two lanes over
and know who that driver
is, know the personality
inside that car.
And you back off.
That is a natural thing to do.
We have this sense
of looking far back.
You can see in your mirror.
You're coming to a stop and
there's this car barreling
down, you put on your flashers.
This is a kind of
long-range sensor
that human beings
have intuitively
once they gain experience.
You look ahead, you
can see brake lights
beginning to go on a
quarter of a mile ahead,
longer than that if it's a hill.
And how will driverless
cars ever get to that level?
I don't know.
It's a big question for me.
I believe that that
kind of human experience
needs to be in the
interface or the environment
would have to change so much.
I mean, they're building
whole town that have sensors.
Well, I don't
imagine Manhattan--
which needs to fix its subways--
is going to put sensors
all around every street
so cars can drive autonomously.
So that to me is
a perfect example.
I have a great feeling about the
movie "Her," if you've seen it.
Scarlett Johansson is
an OS, as they call it,
and she's a being coming
to being in a computer
and she falls in love.
And the whole idea is wanting
to have a human interchange.
And then gradually, she begins
loving hundreds of thousands
of people.
In between one human
word and another,
she has a million interactions
with other computers.
And at some point,
all the OS' disappear.
And it was billed as a movie
about computers wanting
to become human, but actually
it was a story about computers
not wanting to be
human, really enjoying
what it meant to be a
computer, computer to computer.
And I think that was
the story of that film.
DAVID BARRY: OK.
So changing gears again.
So "Life in Code" discusses
a range of subjects--
the nature of coding,
the first tech boom,
lessons to be learned
from the past,
boom two and the
start-up culture--
yet the book is almost
universally described
as a quote women's book.
The editors at "Harper's" titled
the book excerpt gender binary.
The review in the "New
York Times Book Review"
spent half its time on your
gender and the online version
was titled Ellen Ullman's
new book tackles tech's woman
problem.
You've expressed your
annoyance about this.
Could you talk a little more?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Annoyance
is a weak word
to describe how pissed
off I am at this.
I look forward to the
day when a woman who
is experienced in
computing can just
talk about it without a
woman is doing it, oh my god.
There's a woman who
once programmed.
I was actually thinking
of titling the book,
"the Girl Who Writes
the Code" because all
the successful books right
now have girl in the title
and let's just get
it right out there.
And there was a book called
"Lab Girl" about a woman
who was a biologist
and that startled me.
I don't want to talk
about women in tech.
I'm sick of it.
I just had an interview
for an NPR show,
a PRI show, and the
entire half an hour
was spent on the woman question.
Now, I owe this to my
publisher to address this
because it sells books.
It differentiates
me from any number
of people who would write about
technology, and to that extent,
it's good.
But it puts too much
focus on this question
and it mimics what
women go through when
they work in technology.
They're too visible as women.
They are evaluated as women.
They have to be not only good
at what they do, but best--
very good.
I mean, when I
wrote "The Bug," you
have no idea the
number of emails
I got from guys
telling me I didn't
know what I was talking about,
looking for every tiny error.
And I could only
reply, it's fiction.
I have to make things kind of
easy for non-technical readers.
It was really an onslaught.
And this is what I went
through in my own work--
not all men.
I learned so much from
guys I worked with.
They were helpful, they were
geeky in a very pleasant way,
I was geeky myself.
And the more women
who were around,
the easier it was to learn from
men because you weren't just
a woman looking
for help from men.
So I'm not making a broad
generalization about this,
but a woman has a
harder time as--
I guess is this a good
time to bring up the memo?
It's inevitable.
I'm asked about it every time.
So I'll try to be brief because
one could go point by point.
And I'll say that the first
things that were said about it
were kind of explosive.
Even I feel I hadn't
taken the time
to read the memo thoroughly
and read the underlying study
and so it was kind
of these exhortations
and I want to take back some
of that or walk it back.
So after studying the memo
and the study it's based on,
I have a lot of questions.
I'll zero in on one of them.
The study that is taken as
science underlying the memo
is a meta study, it looks
at five other studies.
And we don't actually,
unless you take the time
and you're a researcher, go
and read those five studies.
And all of them are based on a
test called the BFI, big four
inferences or index.
And it measures certain
personality traits--
agreeableness,
wanting to get along--
there's a list of them.
I wrote them down, but
the list is over there.
And one of them is neuroticism.
Now, all the other terms
are fairly neutral.
Why choose neuroticism?
I mean, that's
not a description,
that's a diagnosis.
Right?
Really, it's about tension,
uneasiness, stress, anxiety.
So I would rename it uneasiness.
I think we can just say that's
a good catch-all term that's
more neutral.
So the study, I have a
lot of questions about it.
The five underlying
studies, [INAUDIBLE]
support the meta
study's ideas and that
seems to be cherry-picking.
I could go on and this is
not the forum for that.
But the counterintuitive
finding was
that women in more
advanced cultures,
women in a place where women
had more opportunities,
experienced uneasiness that
was greater than it was
in more traditional cultures.
And so the memo--
I shall leave the
person's name out of it--
took this to mean that, well,
women are having a harder time
and they have more
opportunities.
So let's just say
that sexism is not it,
it's not based on sexism.
I think just the opposite.
First of all, the
study never says,
well, this is counterintuitive;
we should study it more;
let's look at the work
of so-and-so, so-and-so.
Any good study ought to do that.
Why would women in cultures
like ours and Finland and Canada
feel more stressed out?
Because they are forced
to have dual roles.
Women on the whole are forced
to take care of the home--
to clean it, to raise children.
The study never mentions.
It controls for height
and even smoking,
but never mentions
women having children.
This to me is a
tremendous blind spot.
So women are in a
position, most women,
of having to do all the work
at home, raise children.
Lord knows that is
stressful enough.
Even if a woman
doesn't have children,
you care for an
elder who is sick
and then go into this completely
competitive culture like Google
and is expected to perform
not only well but very
well in a place where
she's facing resistance,
is already stressed
out, and has to compete
with some young man
in a t-shirt and jeans
without family responsibilities
who brings a dog to work
and you don't have to
walk the dog at home.
And you compete with that--
anybody, male or female.
If you have to play in two
worlds and do them both well,
I guarantee you're
going to be uneasy.
That is, you will display
a lot of neuroticism.
To me that is the
important point
that's missing in all
of this discussion.
Why are women more
stressed out, if they are.
Now, I question that.
First of all, this is
based on a single study
and that conclusion is
grasped at to prove a point.
And that is the
issue, is sexism,
precisely is sexism because
of the dual roles women
have to play.
Shall I say more or is there
another question we have there?
DAVID BARRY: Yeah.
There's a few more
questions and then
we're happy to take
some audience questions.
ELLEN ULLMAN: I do have--
actually, I realize
I forgot one more thing to say.
The memo says very often
that these efforts are not
good for business.
Why spend all this time trying
to welcome in these people who
have not participated
because it doesn't work
and we're wasting the finite
assets of Google, which really
cracked me up.
I mean, it's finite but
Google has vast resources
that it is spending on a variety
of projects and the efforts
to bring other people in is a
very small part of that budget.
So that was a
bizarre thing to say,
but it is good for business.
When you leave out the possible
contributions, the creativity
of whole classes of people, you
don't know what you're missing.
You're losing talent
in the industry.
And we need fresh values
inside the coding world.
It's a segregated world, mostly
men and Asians, very few women,
very few African-Americans
and Hispanics.
And so inside this
culture, there--
I'll give you an example.
I went to one of
those pitch meetings
where would-be CEOs of start-ups
go and they give their pitch.
And I met a young
man who told me
about his app that
was going to be
used to screen resumes
for a corporation
to find good cultural fit.
So I said to him, well,
good cultural fit is just
a byword for keeping up
the segregated culture.
In other words, you want to hire
people like the ones you have,
who fit in, the people who are
there won't feel uncomfortable
and you're perpetuating
this segregated society
inside the coding world.
And he listened to me patiently
and then he said, well,
all that might be true but
I'm working for the company,
not for society.
And to me that incorporates
the whole problem.
Now, you can't have
them both overlap,
but let's do a Venn diagram
where they move closer together
and overlap.
How much can we have that
overlap between what's
good for business, what's
good for computing,
and what's good for society?
I really question, as we talked
about earlier, the effect
of banishing experts
and the enormous effect
this has had on the
culture globally,
actually, at this point.
So we need new people
to ask new questions.
One borough of New York
City is about to examine
all the algorithms that it
uses to make decisions which
go on who gets to go to
what school, what police
schedules are in
different neighborhoods,
even garbage pickup schedules
in various neighborhoods.
And so one councilman
is saying, I
want to know the bias in here.
I want to know how these
decisions are being made.
And algorithms hide bias, and
especially algorithms that are
written by other algorithms.
And there is one danger
that I just want to mention.
Machine learning
is the topic could,
the work right now in
artificial intelligence.
Computer scientists
and engineers
who are working in this
field, some of them
express the fear or reservation
that once code writes
code writes code,
the original motive
of the creators of that
system lose control over it
and they don't actually
know any more what
the algorithms are doing.
It races away from their
understanding, it gets too big.
And to actually know, well,
what is this thing doing?
Is it doing the work
I thought it would?
Is it making good
decisions or not?
And so another danger of
leaving out the human equation
in algorithms in computing.
I want to add one
thing about why
is it important to bring
people who've been excluded in.
I said new values,
it's good for business.
Now, look, Uber loses $645
million in a single quarter
and does anyone say, well
that's bad for business?
No.
They sustain losses, as
did Amazon for many years,
to grow their business.
So it is possible to
think of these ideas
immediately that are new
ideas and not ask right away,
will this make me money?
The question is, will it
expand the community I serve,
will I get more customers?
And it's worth a try.
If you lose money, you
just keep trying it.
The idea that everything
has to make money
immediately is is a fallacy.
We've seen it all
through the industry.
And one more thing
I want to bring up,
I think we have a
few minutes, is age.
I want to talk about
the value of the past
and what engineers who
are beyond 40, 50 even 60
especially have to contribute
and who have been excluded.
Computing, software engineering
is a young person's profession.
And I think if you
walk around here,
I counted more
dogs in my sample--
I was a half hour early--
than I did people over 40.
That's necessarily
just anecdotal.
But you can ask, what did
other people try before?
I mean, the web page is
horribly like an RPG,
remote programming generator,
in a screen for IBM computer
mainframes in which you
filled out a whole form
and then you hit Send--
which is Enter, which
should be called Submit--
and it comes back with an error.
And you fix that
error, Send, there's
another error, fix
it, another error.
Now, does that sound
like a web page to you?
Yes.
It doesn't go in
and check as you go.
It's avoiding trips
to the server.
I understand it from
an engineering context
why that would be true.
But then of course,
look at all the chatter
to the server with one error,
another error, another error.
So we spent all this time
in client server computing
to bring a client
interface that was richer,
that we could correct errors,
that we could answer questions
locally and minimize
interactions with the server
and do it as we needed.
I think we're way
overbalance now.
If you look at the
history of this,
we're almost back
to the RPG terminal.
We are way over balanced in need
of the server versus the human
being.
And so this is one of these
lessons of the past that
needs to be looked at.
I also-- the idea of
the human curator.
Now, even Google faced this.
The idea was this would
be all algorithmic
and then if you
looked for Jew, you
got Jew Watch, which was a
horribly anti-Semitic site,
it became a pop one.
And Google actually intervened
at the top of this and said,
we recommend you look for
Jewish or Jewish person
because you'll get
a different result.
And that was a
startling interaction
from this company
that was founded
on algorithmic selection.
And we saw what happened to
Facebook, the trending stories.
There were human
curators of that.
And the right said, oh,
they're cherry-picking,
they're trending left.
In reaction, Facebook fired
all of those curators,
those journalists, those
people looking at the stories
and replaced them
with algorithms, which
instantly brought on fake news.
That is the origin of
contemporary fake news.
They were looking
at what is trending.
They saw this tremendous traffic
about some rumor somewhere
that could be perpetuated
among people who
wanted to believe that story.
And it no longer was coming
up with what was trending,
it was coming up with
false information.
Well, what was trending
was false information.
And then Facebook
brought in human curators
again to jury this.
And so we need the human
being in these stories.
If we completely eliminate
the human being, what
we have to offer, our
ability to discriminate,
our subtle abilities
to discriminate--
and intuitively, it's
built into us in evolution.
This is not just some
airy fairy thing.
We survived as a species
having these intuitions.
And what I mean by that is
ability to quickly notice,
thinking fast and slow.
You may know Daniel
Kahneman's work on this.
This is part of what we
have, and to eliminate
this deep store of
abilities is to really
to rob computing of richness.
DAVID BARRY: So you
encourage the general public
to learn to code and you
envision the creation
of an army of coders.
Why?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Well, first
of all to demystify code.
I mean, we're surrounded
by all this stuff
and in the developed world,
you can't get out of it.
Even in undeveloped countries,
they are wrapped in this.
Also the allocation of resources
to them, the study of crops,
decisions on trade.
Essentially, except for the
desperate people of the world--
and that is another out of
the bounds of this talk--
we're wrapped up in this
stuff and we can't escape it.
I can't live without my phone.
Can you?
I can't live
without my computer.
Can you?
If you try, you have to go--
god, how far do
you have to go away
to where you won't get a signal?
So we need to demystify this.
People need to know this is
code, it was written by people,
and uh-oh, if there wasn't
too much machine learning,
it can be changed by people.
Therefore, maybe you
want to look into this.
And I don't mean
everyone should code,
not at all, because it's takes
a very special kind of person.
You have to have a very
high tolerance for failure,
for instance--
bug after bug after bug.
If that's going to make you
nuts, then forget about it.
And have some intrigue
and passion in this.
So I encourage people to try to
learn in some form or fashion
to see if they have
that passion for it,
to find in these
rounds of failure
or some sense of
intrigue, that it's hard
but it's the good hard.
And that will welcome
in, I'm hoping,
people who have been excluded
from the computing culture.
A lot depends on education.
I mean, our society has
de-funded, taken money
away from public schools.
And I don't know how people
will achieve this knowledge.
And so I bring it up so that
we will perhaps as a society
press to make more widespread
knowledge of coding.
Now, I do not mean to raise
computing and learning
programming to the
level of basic literacy.
I think that people who
are basically literate
should invade the coding world.
And actually, as I know it,
Google and other technology
companies are suddenly wanting
to hire philosophers and people
who study in the
humanities, again
to say, well, what are we
missing in history, what
are we missing in what human
beings have learned deeply
about one another?
Novelists know things about
the interior lives of people,
if it's a good novel.
So I can see that this
trend is already underway,
so I'm hoping to bring in
more people in the humanities
and bring in a larger
number of people period who
know how to write code.
I mean, we live in a
world surrounded by code
and a tiny percentage
of people on Earth
have any idea what a
program is, and that clearly
has to be an expanded group.
DAVID BARRY: What can
we do as a society
to foster coding education?
Do you think it should
be part of the curriculum
in public schools?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Not at the
expense of anything else,
I'll say that.
First of all,
reading out of books.
All the studies
show that one learns
very differently and more
deeply turning pages.
Kids who learn from books
retain not only the story,
but associations, as opposed to
on the screen, which literally
is a bounded experience.
So I'm saying in addition.
I'm saying the way
you have to have PE
because it's important for the
body, the way you need recess
because it's important
for the mind.
Oh, by the way, programmers
get out from under your desks
and go home because
it's important to have
other experiences so you
can find those background
regions of your mind where
good ideas come from.
Yes, it should be
available, but I
have to stress to
all social classes.
This cannot just be a privileged
education because then
we're just perpetuating
this culture.
DAVID BARRY: OK.
Well, great.
Well, I think we'll take some
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: You also talked
about the memo and all of that.
So the way I see it, a lot
of times the whole point
if it's raised in a
certain work environment,
it's overcorrected and
then shoved under the rug.
That's how people fix it.
The way I see it
is you have a voice
at the moment in the
technology world.
So have you considered--
and yes, you're sick
of it, but so am I
and I'm just starting to work.
But have you considered
consulting, as you said,
CEOs in big companies are
looking at humanities now
but they weren't before and
you predicted that they should.
So you have insight
into that world.
Have you considered consulting
with CEOs of companies?
Or you mentioned that you should
introduce coding in schools so
have you considered working
with local politicians
to somehow make a
bill out of that?
I'm just curious.
ELLEN ULLMAN: That's very
interesting because my editor,
my friends, there
they're asking,
OK, well, you've got this book.
What do you want to do next?
And I was saying,
well, I don't want
to know what I'm
going to do next,
I want to see what
happens this morning.
I was reading the "Time" and
there was a story about Google
and that one of the employees
of a think tank or research
tank funded by
Google had been fired
because he was questioning
some of Google's practices.
And there was a quote from--
I'm really terrible
with names, I
can tell you strings of numbers
but I'm very bad with names.
Who's the head of Epic?
All right.
This is an electronic monitor.
You may know who.
And I thought, maybe I
should go work for them.
Maybe I should gather a group
of men and women, some of whom
have worked in Silicon
Valley and programming,
who have some funds--
not millionaires, billionaires--
and form our own research
company or our own political
group to advise politicians.
I want to say there has
been this especially
involvement with government
because there has been
this feeling inside
the technical world,
it's mostly been libertarian.
Government is kind of the
enemy, regulations are anathema.
And yet, if companies could
partner with governments,
that would be a very strong
way to have the beneficial--
well, maybe and maybe not.
Maybe they'll partner
with some politicians
who are only on their side.
But yes, I have considered it.
I'm not sure.
I don't think of myself
as having a voice.
I think of this person who
stumbled into computing
because I thought it'd be fun
and all the people involved
were really just
crazy wonderful people
and the kind of people I
liked and had met and worked
with in college and afterward.
But I have been around a
while from the early days
and I have encountered a lot
of what other women are facing
and minorities are facing.
I suppose it is a role that
I have, like it or not,
and maybe I should
learn to like it.
AUDIENCE: When people
talk about technology,
often they talk
about the future.
And there's a lot
of gloom and doom
nowadays for a lot of reasons.
It's seems to me it
used to be the future
was a very happy place.
And maybe you could
say a little about how
you started quite a
while ago in this career
and people talked about
the future back then, too.
How has your sense of the
future changed along the way
and do you think that
everyone's sense of the future
says something about themselves?
ELLEN ULLMAN: That's
an interesting point
in and of itself.
What each individual imagines is
revealing about something deep
inside a person.
The future, I've never thought
of myself as someone who says,
this is what's going to happen.
The fact that some of
these things happen really
disturbs me.
I'm really sorry to
be right about things
like disintermediation and
the unraveling of truths
and the sexism and the exclusion
of the insider engineering
world.
For the future, I am
expecting the next generations
to take this up.
I feel that people of my
generation and prior ones
have a lot of
lessons to pass on.
I mean, people
who work at Google
may think that they're
creating something brand new,
but they stand on the
shoulders of giants.
Algorithms that are
being worked on here
were written back in
the '40s and '50s.
So what we're doing
here is not new.
What future they
are creating, you
are creating can be changed.
It is not this idea that
the future just happens.
Kevin Kelly, he's someone
I deeply disagree with--
I respect him-- wrote a book
called, "What Does Technology
Want?," as if
technology had a motive,
that there was something
inside technology that would
create a world on its own.
No.
What creates technology
is human desire.
It's what you want, what
you envision for the future.
And that's where I say,
it's up to new generations
to take this up.
They have to speak
up for their world.
I mean, as I looked around what
I lived in and just tried to be
clear-eyed and balanced, I--
I'm sorry that some
of the things in here
don't reveal the excitement
I feel about technology,
my love of it and my
skepticism and disappointment.
So I think this generation needs
to sit down and turn their cold
eye on it, not just have this
wonder about the future--
and there will be
wondrous things coming--
but also sit back and go,
oh, what does this mean?
What changes are my
engendering in the world?
What should I question
and what should I love?
They are the future,
they're creating it.
So that the future doesn't
just happen, people make it.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Sort of.
ELLEN ULLMAN: Sort of.
OK.
Go back and ask it again.
AUDIENCE: A different
question if it's OK.
It's about religion.
I don't know if you give much--
I have not read your book
yet, I will read it--
so I don't know if you
comment on religion.
Among the many experts who are
being disintermediated lately
are religious experts.
And religious people
don't just talk about God,
they also talk about
right and wrong.
They're among the many
people who will explain
to you why lying is bad.
But these sorts
of experts are not
being listened to as they were.
Do you imagine that this has
any impact on what we see now?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Well, it's
not only religious people.
There are people of good will
and good faith in human beings
who bring up these issues.
My questions are moral and
we do miss those voices.
Matter of fact, people who
lie say they're against liars.
OK?
Donald Trump lies and
he's against fake news.
So yes, we are missing those
voices who are authoritative.
They know what
they're doing, right?
And say, no, a lie is a lie.
Mistreating someone is wrong.
There are injustices
that we need to right.
Yes, they've been
left out, certainly.
And unfortunately, some
of those religious voices
are extremely right-wing.
And so it's complicated.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Can you
say a little bit
about your experience
working on the audio books?
Did you get any guidance as far
as acting sort of direction?
ELLEN ULLMAN: No.
My publisher said, well--
actually Macmillan FSG is a
wonderful literary imprint
within this huge
corporation called Macmillan
and they do the audio books.
And they said, well,
we'd really like
you to do it because when
we have nonfiction books,
we like the author to
read it, especially
since a lot of your book, most
of it is in the first person.
So I heard it would be grueling,
but I was encouraged to do it.
So I did it.
No, I just walked in cold.
I mean, I've had some
public speaking experience.
And actually, singing
is what turned out
to helped me the most, breath
control over periods of time.
But no, I went in this booth,
I put on some headphones,
there was the book
in front of me--
actually, it was on a
iPad, no pages noise--
and I just started
from page one.
And we did 100 pages a
day to finish the book.
It was a grueling experience.
Luckily, you don't have to read
through like you're on a stage.
You can just back up at
any punctuation point
and go forward.
But it was quite an experience.
And people who drive--
there were many people who just
read audio books while they
commute, so I'm hoping
that some of those people
will pick it up.
DAVID BARRY: I think you're
kind of unique in the sense
that you're a very advanced
programmer and coder
and then you've
gone on to become
a really successful writer.
So writing in code is a
certain type of language
and then writing in English in
the literary way that you do
is also another
type of language.
So could you talk maybe about
the parallels between those two
or if there's any synergies and
what maybe learning to write
in code has--
if it has at all influenced
the way that you write
or the way that you
think about writing?
ELLEN ULLMAN: Well, code
expresses itself by running,
by working.
Its meaning is what it does.
An algorithm can be beautiful.
It can express elegance.
But finally, what it
does is what it means.
In writing, you never
know when it works.
Your idea is to
say, OK, that works.
But there's no compiler,
there's no tester,
there's nothing there
except your own facility.
Coding taught me to focus
and have stamina and have
the resolve to solve problems.
It's hard, but a good hard.
And writing is also
hard and a good hard.
The overlap in languages,
I'm afraid I don't see.
As I say, code can have elegance
but one is very structured
and you have requirements about
how you're going to write code.
You have style you have to
follow with an organization
and code reviews and so forth.
The code review in a book is
well, will people read it,
will they like it?
Language is
expressive and you can
say things that are
just wrong grammatically
and people will
understand it anyway.
That's one of its beauties.
People who come from
different cultures
can write sort of
in hip-hop, they
can write in code
of the Caribbean
like [INAUDIBLE]
Diaz, they can really
use language and juggle
it or be extremely formal.
And they're all valid
means of expression
in language, and that you can
do it wrong and still have it
work is one of the wonderful
things about language.
DAVID BARRY: OK.
Well, thank you,
everyone, for coming.
Thank you, Ellen,
so much for coming.
ELLEN ULLMAN: Thank you.
DAVID BARRY: Let's have a
round of applause, please.
ELLEN ULLMAN: It's
been my pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]